And finally, new rule:
since so much of what passes
for today's journalism is
anything but,
how about some rules for
identifying actual news?
For example, when an internet
headline reads:
"You won't believe..."
Yes, you will,
and no, it's not news.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
When anyone is demanding an
apology,
unless they have hostages,
that's not news.
And when the offended group
are identified as
"the internet", "Twitter",
or "people"?
-It's nobody!
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I guarantee, when you click
on the story you find out
"the internet" is three losers
with a combined
Twitter following of their mom.
(APPLAUSE)
I used to think
something was news
if a journalist reported it.
But really, I live in a world
where it's news
if Mariah Carey's tit flops out,
because Twitter will respond
and then a "journalist" reports
on the controversy.
If a boob flops in the forest,
and no one is around to hear it,
it doesn't make a sound.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
But if three jackasses tweet
about it, it's news.
Here's an example
from this week.
This is a picture from the
premiere of Red Sparrow,
which looks pretty good,
by the way.
Jennifer Lawrence plays
a beautiful woman who uses
sex as a weapon
on orders from Moscow.
It's working title was
I, Ivanka.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
You were way ahead of me
on that one. (CHUCKLES)
Anyway, here's the headline from
Elle Online and 100 other sites.
"Jennifer Lawrence's Latest
'Red Sparrow' Photocall
Has Twitter Calling Out
Gender Inequality"
Yes, see, see, 'cause the men
are wearing coats but she's not.
And even though that was her
choice,
someone with 11 followers
didn't like it, so the "story"
was reported
in The New York Times,
The Washington Post,
New York Post, Fox News, BBC,
Vanity Fair, Chicago Tribune,
The Guardian, National Review.
Now, all these esteemed news
organizations aren't saying
they think it's a big deal,
because they are serious
journalists.
They'd rather be writing about
Syria and the oceans dying.
But, oh, the humanity.
Jennifer Lawrence
didn't have a coat.
Wrap her up! Wrap her up!
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
You know,
this is not an outlier.
This is a constant and prominent
part of today's journalism.
Creating some bullshit non-issue
that a few trolls
will predictably go apeshit over
and then reporting on those
unrepresentative tweets,
like all of America is talking
about nothing else.
"Justin Timberlake used
a projection of Prince
for his Super Bowl halftime show
and people are furious."
-No. Nobody cared.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
People are really mad that
Shaun White dragged
the American flag
after he won the gold.
No. Not even a little,
you fucking liars.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
"Weight Watchers is targeting
teens and Twitter is outraged."
No, it isn't! It's the same
three people, and it's not hard
to find three people who
are mad at anything.
I could say, "Good morning"
on Twitter and three people
would object.
"Good in your privileged world,
Bill Maher!"
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
No wonder fake news resonates
so much with Trump fans.
'Cause so much of it is fake!
Just nonsense made to keep you
perpetually offended
with an endless stream
of controversies
that aren't controversial,
and outrages that aren't
outrageous.
Because places like
The Huffington Post,
and Buzzfeed, and Salon,
they make their money
by how many clicks they get.
Yes, the people who see
themselves as morally superior
are actually ignoring their
sacred job
of informing citizens of what's
important,
and instead, sowing division
for their own selfish ends.
Hey, wait. Isn't that what
Russia was doing to us?
Yeah, it is.
And we have to stop
both of them
from using us as the cocks
in their cockfights.
And so I conclude by saying
to all those
who are barely able
to go on
after seeing Kendall Jenner
tweet the wrong color emoji...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...a bit of advice
if you don't like what Kendall
did with a brown fist
in her tweet?
Do not watch
her sister's sex tape.